hi everyone welcome and thank you for
joining us for the whisper fine tuning
speaker events uh we hope that you've
enjoyed the first day of the event and
have been making the most of the fine
tuning scripts and compute allocation uh
we're very fortunate that we have two
excellent speakers who are going to be
talking to us
um and we're joined first by John Woo
Kim from open AI uh John group is a
technical member of staff at open Ai and
he's worked on projects such as jukebox
clip and most recently whisper uh we're
extremely fortunate to have John group
talk to us today about whisper
especially given that it's the model
around which we're centering this event
so feel free to ask questions in the
sidebar uh we're in depth to answer as
many of them as possible at the end of
the talk and without further Ado I'll
hand over the John group
thank you sanchit and hi everyone uh I'm
I'm excited to have this thought thanks
for having me uh the title The Talk will
be about uh just a quick introduction to
whisper and uh
some motivations and results around the
model
so let's start with a quick detour uh to
the computer vision literature
so you might uh probably all remember
that image that moment it's just about
10 years ago uh where the Deep learning
based model
um kind of over
through the other traditional models and
since then the image net performance
have been improving uh
like ever since
um so the top five error was the initial
metric that have that people have been
competing on and it started with 16
which was amazing at the time and then
the top five error became like single
digit percent and uh things like resnet
and after people achieved three percent
or lower top five errors and that's
about when people realize that that's
too easy of a Target so they switched to
top one accuracy and then most recently
uh the the state-of-the-art models
exceeds 90 accuracy uh just top one so
uh but the human error on that uh by the
way this imagenet classification is
classifying images into 1000 classes so
it's very taunting task for even a very
expert human
uh and the human error on that uh is
believed to be about five percent or so
um so these models are very good at
classifying images and this is uh can be
argued to be a superhuman but are these
uh Visa models actually superhuman are
they like better than anything uh on the
on the task of classifying images
um and I I I guess uh everyone would
agree that this is not actually we are
we don't have uh full self-driving yet
and
um these Visa models are not as reliable
as uh just uh humans on many tasks other
than classifying images on this specific
image data set
uh that was the motivation behind the
developing clip the previous project I
have worked on and the clip is trained
on very simple tasks of matching text
and images uh like this uh question that
you probably have solved in kindergarten
so you have a bunch of images and the
corresponding text descriptions and the
task is just to connect those uh text
image Pairs and we do this on 400
million image taxpayers on collected
from the internet
yep so as a result uh we got a very
robust classifier so on the imagenet
classification task you uh just saw on
the previous graph we get the same
accuracy as the resnet 101 model which
is more than five years old at the time
of announcement of clip but
um
the drawback of the resident one-on-one
model was that if you use that
classifier and apply them on the similar
set of images but slightly differently
looking like we have sketches of the
banana here and some some Renditions so
drawings or something else on the of the
banana that's not actually bananas and
um yeah some other difficult data sets
and you see that Resident 101 performs
way
lower than the original
and then on the original imagenet data
set but click model manages to have
similar level of
actresses uh across these difficult data
sets
so if you plot the accuracies uh from
the image that the original image the
model on the x-axis and the other image
image that like data sets on the y-axis
you typically see those uh dots all on
the blue lines where uh that is from non
like that is just the models trained on
just imagenet
that data but clip achieves a way higher
here so it means that for given uh
certain accuracy number from the
original imagenet data set clip also
performs better on the other data sets
uh so we are calling it this effective
robustness and uh this is something
that's very good to have
so
let's think about a little of a bit of
distribution uh so let's
say that they speak
uh sky blue circle is a space of all
images and I would say that uh about a
million images from the original
imagenet data set training split uh is
occupying a small portion of the
imagenet data and
the accuracy that you saw on the first
row of the figure is evaluated on the
very small the smallest Circle which is
representing the test set of the
imagenet data set so if you train a
model on just a
this medium orange circle of the data
and test on this even smaller circle of
the data
the model
is learned to perform in distribution
inference so it performs well on this
specific test that
because this is within the distribution
of imagenet data but it will often
struggle with something that's very far
away on the space of all images
on the other hand click
is
uh this is like a hand wave the hand
wavy diagram but the 400 million images
to train are collected from uh the
Internet it's not necessarily in the
same distribution of the image net test
set so uh when it's doing inference on
imagenet it's doing out of distribution
inference so when we are measuring out
of distribution uh performance it is
very difficult to make it better so uh
when when you have some number that is
out of distribution uh
performance that is good or we can uh
arguably predict that it'll be much more
robust so that's uh basic motivation
behind training up clip and as a result
uh this clip embeddings are very general
and uh that was a part of the reason uh
how the Dali model which is basically
inverting the clip embedding into back
into images uh was able to be very
successful at this time
yep so that was a little bit of
backstory about the development of clip
and the reason why I uh started with the
story of clip and computer vision was
that the motivation behind developing
whisper was basically that
so uh here is kind of similar graphs so
similar to imagenet
people have been people in the speech
recognition text speech to text
literature was working on a data set
called Liberty speech and uh Through The
Years uh from 2016 to uh 21 uh
the models set of the art models have
been improving uh and improving uh Way
Beyond what's believed to be a human
level accuracy so here uh we are
denoting the word error rate and it's
lower the better and uh in in this 2020
paper uh they say they achieved below
two percent of world data rate uh but
why why that why doesn't it work so well
with my voice or
um
like one percent water already it's
amazing but you don't really expect uh
Siri or
um any commercial speech recognition
software to perform this level of
accuracy
so I would argue that this very same
thing is happening in this space uh so
there is a liberty speech 960 hour data
set and the models state of the art
uh speech recognition models have been
either pre-training or fine-tuning on
this specific data set and testing on
the even smaller test splits of the this
data set so uh you think of the imagenet
uh parallel uh it's no wonder that uh
why uh why this liberal speech fine tube
model doesn't work very well on other
distribution of voices such as uh random
stream from YouTube or something
so for whisper we took the same approach
of collecting uh as many as diverse as
possible of our data from the internet
and the college to be a uh 680 000 hours
of audio and in the end it's performing
out of distribution inference uh to
measure the performance on liberal
speech but not only in the wrist speech
but much more it's performing well on
much more diverse set of audio
so uh let me jump to the architecture of
the model
so the model starts with a log Mouse
spectrogram which is a direct conversion
of the audio input to the time frequency
domain and it goes through a very simple
two layer convolutional layers and the
rest of it is just very standard encoder
encoder decoder Transformer and by
designing a certain special tokens that
I will talk about very shortly the model
is able to do English transcription or
some non-english transcription
translation from some non-english
language to English and transcribing a
non-english language into that script
and also it has some of the ability to
detect no speech so if the audio content
did not contain the speech it's able to
classify that
yep so this is the uh
special tokens that I mentioned uh and
this orange color is uh the special
tokens and
the blue ones are uh the normal text
tokens and in addition we have the green
timestamp tokens that indicates the uh
timings along with the text
um so from the beginning uh we have an
option to start with this startup
transcript token and following that we
first predict the language tag uh where
we where we have about 90 something uh
language test separate tokens for each
of them and uh either that or the no
speech token and then following the
language tag uh there are two options
transcribe and translate and this these
two are what we give to the model what
the prefix the generation to indicate if
you want to transcribe uh the text into
the spoken language or translate the
speech into English script
and uh we have another option after that
uh just to begin with the timestamp or
begin with the another special no
timestamps token and if the No Time
stamps token is present the
following tokens are just text tokens
only and in the other case we can start
with the
uh in the in the other case we the model
produces
sequence of segments and each segment
starts with a begin time and the text
tokens and the end time and after all
these scripts are produced the model
will likely output the end of text token
and in addition to all this uh the model
have an option to start with a special
token called prev and Then followed by
uh this previous text tokens and this
can be used for prompting the model so
this can be something that might have
come before
what's in the audio was said
um yeah so using this unified set of
token schemes uh you can do multilingual
speech transcription translation and
language identification and voice
activity detection to some degree
um this is the robustness plot uh that
kind of parallels with the clip figure
uh again it's lower uh it's better and
the typical Libre speech Trend or model
are along these blue lines uh where they
perform very well on the Libre speech
data set just two or three percent water
rate but uh way worse on more difficult
data sets like common voice time and Ted
whereas uh the whisper models are along
this purple line and you see that
although it they don't necessarily
perform better than uh other libraries
between models on the Libre speech data
set uh
they are they show much lower water rate
on the other data sets that are more
difficult and much more
like real world scenarios and we have
another dot uh by our author Olek
um and he tested uh a few hundred
examples from each of these data sets
and we learned that the dot is is lying
on the same trend line as the whisper
models so from this figure we can kind
of handwavely argue that the whisper
models are kind of similar trajectory as
the human
uh robustness on English speech
Yep this is another figure showing the
robustness of the of the whisper models
so uh the red red lines
and sorry
um the scrap is showing how the model
performs when we add some additive noise
so because audio is just a single uh
stream of audio samples we can add noise
to it very easily and uh depending on
the noise levels it's still Audible and
it's kind of simulating speech in a very
noisy environment but like right next to
airplanes or on in a very noisy pubs and
you add more noise as you are going to
the right and you see that on the
leftmost point which is basically no
noise environment uh whisper models are
showing higher order rate than the other
state-of-the-art models uh like this
green lines are from Nvidia Nemo
framework and the blue line is a nice
one from Facebook wave to Vector based
model
but if you add as you add more noise
additive noise to it uh obviously the
order rate is going to be increasing but
the error rate of whisper stays lower
compared to the other models especially
for more realistic noises about uh the
case of the pop noise pop noise sounds
like I'm not sure if the audio is
playing but yeah this is a typical like
recording from very like unidentifiable
speech and noise from noisy Pub
uh
English as our performance of whisper is
uh very close to the human performance
so uh depending on the model size the
English accuracy uh kind of slows down
on improving uh so the accuracy is on
medium and large models are not so much
different
and the reason why it could be inferred
uh because we show that The Whisper
model these are some data sets 525 or so
as speech samples and measured the water
rate of based on different ASR method as
well as human transcription services and
we see that the human transcription
accuracies are not very much different
from the whisper model's accuracy so
even if risper model improves by
significantly from this uh we see that
it could not probably be like much
slower than this uh seven percent for
example
uh so on the multilingual side uh we see
a very interesting trend on the accuracy
versus the hours of training data that
we have and you it's about halving the
word error rate every 16-fold data
increase so
it kind of gives you the direct roadmap
for improving multilingual data sets
multilingual performance uh is just to
have 16 times more data if you want to
house the accuracy
um and the only figures on the right
shows that
shows the model uh performance depending
multilingual performance on as a
function of model parameters you see
that unlike English the multilingual
performances increase as a function of
model parameter more steadily and it
could be argued that up to medium model
it's more focusing on the English model
kind of for the large model it kind of
stops learning English and then focusing
on the multilingual side
more so
this whisper has been out for about uh
two months inch now and uh they're
having already some um cool real world
applications I'm Andre carpathy made
this uh Lexi cap website where he uh ran
whisper on all of the luxury Lex
Friedman podcast and have this navigable
transcript
uh I learned that at the snipped the uh
company used whisper to
produce transcripts for the podcast
and this recent example uh that we
learned is using whisper to transcribe
Apollo missions uh control tether which
is uh 7 000 hours and I'll be daunting
to uh for the humans to work on all of
them
uh and an exciting news to share today
is that uh I just pushed a better large
model just a few minutes ago so you can
pull from the official repository of
whisper and load the large model and it
will show that five to ten percent
improved performance
um yeah and I'm sure uh that the hugging
Phase 10 will be of reflecting this uh
new checkpoint on their live versions as
well
yep there are some limitations of the
whisper model as it's currently
published uh one uh
drawback is inaccurate timestamp because
the raw data has very uh non-even
distribution of timestamps so it may
produce uh like it may opt to produce
integer time stamped as opposed to
millisecond level timestamps uh but it
could be a little bit of uh overcome a
little bit by uh giving
prompt or tinkering with the
distribution project infrared
distribution of the timestamps a little
bit to reduce the bias on the integer
timestamps
hallucinations are one issue it will
sometimes say something that is not at
all spoken in the input audio
and we are working on finding ways to
reduce those
um and as you saw it has relatively low
performance on low resource languages
and I guess it's the main main purpose
of this hackathon so I'm excited about
it
um and it doesn't have speaker like
tagging or recognition or tracking
capabilities it could have some
representation about the speaker in the
model but the current output format
doesn't really support this so this this
could be another big um interesting
Target for fine tuning
and it doesn't currently support
real-time transcription because it takes
a 30 seconds of audio at a time uh but
uh there have been some some interesting
applications uh
which took like incrementally
incremental audio every second and then
produced near real-time outputs so we're
improving on that front is another
interesting
uh directions for this hackathon I guess
um and lastly the implementation is just
using pure Pi torch but if people sell
the pi torch 2 announcement there'll be
much effort going on improving this
python uh only inference performance uh
by compiling the repetitive calls to the
GPU into a single kernel launch so that
uh has like very big potential to
improve the inference speed uh I guess
we have about the Headroom about like
five to ten times in front speed up so
that's another uh technically
challenging but interesting
uh direction for hackathons
right this is the last slides that we
have and uh should I take some questions
onto
hey yeah thanks very much I think so
we've got some really good questions in
the sidebar so directly through them to
you uh so Shaq mixed food asks
um could you please elaborate why audio
was not considered as an input in the
place of log mail spectrograms
oh
um that was just a design choice that uh
we don't have like a good experiment
comparing the two
um so I I guess
yeah we thought that the mouse platform
has been standard for uh speech
recognition for quite a while and it has
surprisingly dense amount of information
uh like when you compare number of
pixels and number of samples in the
audio uh so that's one thing and I
personally look very much like the spec
program or time frequency uh kind of
representation and
um for at least for recognition like
this if you're not generating them uh I
I would argue that this is uh just as
good of our representation as raw audio
um then the reason one more reason that
why I like those special program
representation is that uh it conveys
very physical meaning so if it it has
this like pitch curves uh that you can
see visually
um
and some some amplitude changes become
constant shift in this log male
spectrograms which is another nice
property uh to have when you think of
because the
model should be more or less invariant
to the amplitude changes and it's it's
nice to have those kind of things
yep thanks very much uh Jessica asks uh
what's the intuition between having
timelined transcriptions and no
timestamps in your training objective
and uh would uh disregarding the
timeline transcriptions help with the
overall speech recognition or
translation objective if you simplify
the task
yeah um
so if you so the main reason uh why we
added this no timestamp mode is to allow
for easier fine tuning
and we haven't uh included much of a
fine tuning performance studies but uh
many of the data sets like Libra speech
or common voice they are usually short
audio like 10 to 30 seconds
um and they don't have like many
granular timestamp uh
information other than just a text
corresponding to that 10 seconds of
audio so when we want to fine-tune those
data sets we don't necessarily have this
timestamps token to use that information
to build those time tokens so uh I uh I
was yeah we were thinking that we could
just default to this node time step mode
and then just text tokens will be
something that's a model will be
fine-tuned to produce so that was the
main motivation and in terms of the
actresses between these two modes of
generation we didn't see any significant
uh differences uh
yeah and that's thanks to the amazing
generalization capabilities of
transforming models
thanks very much
um so uh one question is um
has have has there been any exploration
into integration with an external
language model was the decoder of the
Wisp model sufficient to achieve
good transcription
um we haven't unfortunately but the way
that we the decoder is built uh it's
just Ultra regressive Transformer just
like language models so uh if you uh
want to just train another set of AR
language models based on the same
tokenization I guess it'll be simplest
to integrate but also you could just uh
just totally separate language models
and then compare
uh the generations of uh the inferred
distribution of tokens versus the
language models predictions to select
the tokens so I'm not familiar with how
the hugging face versions of uh decoding
is implemented but for the official
repository uh I had some some like
object-oriented designs of uh decoding
logic so that it's relatively easier to
integrate those kind of language model
based uh sequence ranking or token
selections or something like that
so yeah I guess uh for non-english
transcripts I've seen um some spelling
errors in Korean or Japanese and I've
seen reports of similar stories for
Greek as well so
um I think language model integration
could be a nice way to even improve the
multilingual performances
I guess if you if you have a specific
language in mind as well then also
fine-tuning would likely help right like
if you if you give more data to French
in the detail yeah totally
yeah because I I guess that the reason
why the uh spelling errors happen like
those are spelling errors that of the
words that that's like not not on the
dictionaries at all and those kind of
things and I I we are we are guessing
that that's because of the already uh
like automatically transcribed text that
has spelling errors because like phony
matters uh that got into our training
data
so uh yeah something like language model
could fix it very easily
cool and uh just a final question so you
kind of investigated the different sizes
of the whisper models and the impact
that scaling that the Western model had
uh did you do you have any Intuition or
insight as to whether there's relative
importance with the size of the encoder
or size of the decoder does it matter
more to have a large and deep encoder to
get a good audio representation
oh just having like a large detail to
help with the orthographic fully
formatted transcriptions as well
uh we unfortunately unfortunately don't
have that that ablation uh there could
be an interesting one to study uh but
yeah in a general like sense uh
uh that number like differences doesn't
matter significantly in many cases so we
kind of default it to the very basic
designs of having the same number of
incorrect decoder layers
cool thank you very much so um I think
we've hit half an hour so uh I think
we'll we'll draw we'll draw a line map
but yeah thank you so much to John Luke
for the Fantastic presentation I'm sure
yeah thank you for having me my pleasure
extremely enjoyable So yeah thank you
thank you very much and uh extremely
motivating now for us to go and take
this model that we know more about and
and fine tune in the language languages
of our choice
um so that's the first of two talks in
uh in this speaker event
um so we'll we'll resume back here in
half an hour uh just some two quick
announcements before before you leave us
uh the first is to just double check the
instructions on the readme if you're
redeeming Lambda GPU credits then uh
there are some detailed instructions on
how you can sign up and the process that
you need to carry out to to get your
free credits and then we also remind you
to shut down your gpus when you're not
using them to save your credits for fine
tuning uh and the second announcement is
that Lander hosting a giveaway
um so if you uh if you tweet hugging
face and Lambda uh with the results of
your training run and if you tag them in
between then you'll be entered into a
giveaway with the chance of winning 300
hours of 1x a 100 credits so we'll give
you more details about that in the
Discord and uh look forward to seeing
you all in half an hour
relax
hello
all right
yes
yes
so we're we're actually live right now
but uh maybe we can just quickly do a
quick check of um whether we're able to
add your
um slides to the Stream
okay
um I think already I'm sharing my screen
so okay perfectly uh I mean it works
perfect uh
awesome
okay that's great so I think we had like
three four minutes until we kick off so
um we can uh yeah we can we can make
start then but yeah I just do a brief
introduction and then hand over hand
over to you to take it away
but yeah thanks very much for agreeing
to do this talk we're very very excited
to have you have you speak and also
share the boss property data set with
the participants so
it should be extremely exciting
yeah
um yeah thanks for having me here um
today
be based in New York right
yes I'm based in New York
afternoon afternoon time and it's not
too it's not too early then the
foreign
and then uh I'm gonna add your
um slides as soon as you start um
talking GitHub works
okay sounds good
perfect
okay well we're just like 30 seconds
around we can tweaking again yeah
thank you
okay uh hey everyone welcome back to the
second half of the talk events for the
whisper fine tuning event
um very excited to bring you the the
second of the two talks and uh this talk
will be presented by Chang and one uh
changing is a research engineer at
meta's fundamental AI research Fair uh
mainly working on natural language and
speech processing uh if you participated
in the robust speech event earlier this
year you will have heard changing speak
on the topic of xlsr at the talk events
and uh today we're very fortunate enough
to have China return to speak on box
properly which is a recent data set
published and as data unlabeled data in
over 20 in 23 languages and supervised
data in 15 languages so without further
Ado I'll hand over to China
right um thanks essential for the
introduction
um and thanks for having me here today
um so hi everyone uh I'm Chung Han I'm a
research engineer from meta AI in New
York so I'm really working on speech
translation and speech representation
learning so um today I'm going to talk
about box properly which is a large
scale multilingual speech Corpus this is
a joint work with my colleagues at meta
AI
so Vox property is currently the largest
open multilingual speech Corpus um it's
a versatile cover is providing data for
various speech tasks like speech
representation learning speech
recognition and speech translation
so here's the overview of the various
kinds of data that properly provides
so basically Vox probably has some 400
000 hours of unlabeled speech data in 23
European languages and it has 1.8 000
hours of transcript speech data in 16
languages so this includes 29 hours of
accented English speech from non-native
English speakers
and Box Company also has special speech
translation and speechless text
translation data for 15 to 15 language
directions with a total duration of 17.3
000 hours of speech data
to get to create works properly
um we collect data from European Union
Parliament event recordings from 2009 to
2020 which contains beaches in 23 EU
languages and their simultaneous
interpretations into other EU languages
the data is auditory and in a political
domain
the raw data from the EU website suffers
from accurate transcriptions and
delayments from the speech to its
transcription or interpretation
we developed data processing pipelines
to accurately align each speech with
their transcription and interpretation
if they are available
we segment four event recordings into
speeches by by speaker and then further
segmented into utterances so that they
have a proper length for model training
and finally we filter our potential
potentially mislined data or
mistranscript data
most probably data has brought
applications in various speech tasks so
first it provides 1.8 000 hours of
transcribed speech in 16 European
languages which is useful for training
and evaluating speech recognition models
the data distribution by language is
imbalanced leading to data conditions
spanning from high resource settings
like over 500 hours for English
um to low result settings like only 10
hours of speech data for Slovenia
full box properly speech recognition
Benchmark we provide Transformers
supervised baselines for the top 14
languages as shown in the table at the
bottom right we can see that low
resource languages in this Benchmark are
challenging for example both Croatia and
Slovenia have less than 50 hours of
speech data and have over 40 rate on
both the devset and test set
besides the transcribe speech data for
speech recognition tasks
um what's probably also has as much as
400 000 hours of unlabeled speech data
for 23 EU languages although the data
distribution by language is imbalanced
as well for for this case it still has
at least 8 000 hours of data for each of
the 23 languages
and even has over 20 000 hours of data
for the top six languages
thank you
the large amount of Vox purpley are
labeled speech data is useful for speech
pre-training and speech representation
learning here we take with the back 2.0
model as an example we use a 10 000 hour
subset of the Box property and label
speech data for with 2.0 model training
this data is in the same domain as the
property speech recognition data and
then we fine-tune the pre-trained models
using transcribed data
we see from the table that pre-training
brings consistent gains on all the
languages against the supervised
Transformer baselines
and it leads to average 60 percent
reduction on the world average rate
in meta AIS later work we leverage the
full 400 000 hour data from vox populi
to build xosr a set of multilingual wave
to back 2.0 models for 128 languages
um with larger scale training data we
also scaled access our model sizes to up
to 2 billion parameters so both standard
skating and model skating make xlsr
generalized well across different
languages and domains
on the Vox public speech recognition
Benchmark the xosr One beta models
improve the Box properly 10 000 hour
models by average 31 were array
reduction
and earlier this year hacking face
already organized a fine tune event for
our xlsr models so feel free to to check
out these previous models for your
reference
the Box properly are labeled speech
there is also useful in self training
which is common semi-supervised learning
technique basically we first pursue
label and label data with a supervised
model and then combine labeled and
pursue label data to train a new model
in our paper we evaluate self training
which works properly enabled speech data
on two tasks many speech recognition and
speech-to-text translation
as shown in the table self-chaining
brings performance gains to both Vox
property domain in a different domain
namely the common voice domain on both
ASR ASP Shield tax translation tasks
we also see that against
um increase as we use more box property
and label speech data for self-training
besides a large amount of unlabeled
speech data works properly also provides
a large amount of data for
speech-to-speech translation and speech
to speech to speech to text translation
it covers the translation from 15
languages to other 15 languages
the speech-to-speech translation data
involves properly is from our
interpretation which tends to be
summarizing with important details
dropped this is something like a recent
translation which is verbatant and exact
human interpreters regularly apply these
tactics to make better quality latency
trade-offs during the translation when
trend on the interpretation data speech
to speech translation models is likely
to benefit from these human techniques
however open interpretation data was
rare in the past but now works properly
provides abundant data to enable this
field of study
also as a derivative of the special
speech translation data box property
also provides speech to text translation
data so this data is actually labeled as
we use interpretive speech for the
source side which is summarizing and use
the original transcript for speech for
the Target side which is verbatant
so in your paper we also evaluate this
data using the same setting as the one
used for self-chaining experiments
um we see from the table that combining
we could labeled speech to text
translation data from Vox public with
the labeled data from existing speech to
text translation data sets brings up to
28 more gains than using self training
to improve speech to trans text
translation and it's much more efficient
than a self-chaining which level is only
unlabeled data
so we only use 400 hours of weekly
labeled data while there is um 3 000
hours of
unlabeled data used for um cell chaining
um so we already released the Vox
property data and models under
permissive licenses they can be found on
both hacking face website and also our
GitHub repo
um whose links are provided in this
slide also feel free to contact hack
investing or contact me if we have any
question when using this data and models
so to summarize
um Vox property is the largest open
multilingual speech Corpus which has
brought applications so it's used for in
various speech tasks including speech
representation learning semi-suffized
learning speech recognition and speech
translation
and feel free to check out box 40 data
and models on hacking face or GitHub
okay so that's all for my presentation
um thanks for your attention and now I'm
happy to take questions
hey thanks so much for the talk channel
uh so our first question is um so with
the example of Slovenian where there was
only 10 hours of label data but that was
over those 10K hours of unable data does
this mismatch come about because of a
lack of labeled data from European
Parliament recordings uh or is the data
just uh do we do we lose a lot of data
through the data filtering steps like is
there the potential to have more data in
these low resource languages
um yeah so so I would say it's like from
both so like from the data source like
um the data is already in Balance
because I guess for uh Slovenia um I
mean species for Slovenia is like um of
um roughly lower uh percentage in the
Raw data and also um it's harder to um
ensure the data quality like because we
apply automatic pipeline to process the
data and filter data and we kind of
trying to set a high confidence when
when
um applying this pipeline to ensure the
quality of the data
um so I think they're also
hypersensitive data being filtered out
because Slovenia is over a low resource
language and we want to ensure like
after the alignment
um and also the filtering we still have
high quality data and kind of status
transfer for that
thanks uh you mentioned with a speech
speech translation that there was the um
it was the case that the the target
speech is less verbatim than say written
transcriptions does that pose like a
limitation to the training speech speech
systems or could that be a benefit that
you get very compact uh Target
representations for your for your speech
to speech models
um yeah yeah this is a very good
question so I think in the real
application like of like special speech
translational interpretation
um I think
um we we're kind of trying to
um so from from this um data sauce
because it's like real like human
interpretation data we also um
want to
um
like enable models like create data set
for email models who mimic like human
um tactics for the interpretation
um because for the speech on uh through
speech translation we also care about
the latency it is a bit unlike the
speech to text translation where you may
have the text translation
um
projected on the screen while for speech
um translation on slash interpretation
like you might usually have a short
memory so it's important to at least
convey the most important information
um in the original speech instead of
keeping all the details and this also
helped to reduce the the
um the latency for for the translation
given like really long um input for
example for translation
so we've got some other good questions
in the in the uh in the comments so one
is a for the low resource languages
um especially those with Highwood
aerates uh is that is that the
possibility of exploring using say TTS
models to have some kind of like back
translation to to potentially convert
some of that written transcription into
audio text pairs
um yeah I think that's a very good idea
I think like um several recent papers
like with some errors like trained to
um use a small number of um ASR data um
the the speech text on paired data to
train and TTS model and then use that
TTS model for um data orientation like
generating more data and add it into
um to the label data to train a new
model and I think that uh that that's a
very effective approach to improve and
performance
um
thanks uh we've got a question of what
kind of speaker information is provided
in the transcribed data and is there a
way of using any of this information to
improve our ASR performance or do we
just need to rely on the audio and text
um so um so in your paper like we didn't
actually try to leverage the speaker
information to improve the ASR baselines
but we do provide a speaker IDs for for
the speech in the is our data
so these like spear ideas are from the
raw um I mean the the website
so our accurate information for the
speaker
um besides that I've also applied um
um model to predict the gender of the
speaker this is kind of a part of a
sanity check of our data while we
release the data we want to ensure like
we have a good amount of
um data from female and speakers uh when
we release data so we also provide these
like model predicted labels for the
speaker agenda um in the data release
thanks so we'll have a couple more
questions and concern asks what kind of
tools or libraries do you use to
quantify the quality of audio data sets
like Fox probably so I guess it's
referring kind of to your filtering out
stages and when you do your data
cleaning how do you how do you quantify
what determines a noisy or yeah the
quality of the audio data sets
um yeah so basically our data processing
pipelines like automatic so we have some
in-house um we're applying house um ASR
models and also LED models too to do the
data filtering and worry so um like
higher human inspectors to to look into
Data to ensure like um we like the say
the hyper parameters the stress we set
for data filtering is reasonable to
ensure like high quality
um all these 16 languages
and then in terms of the Vox Property
Data itself is it possible to put a
label on the the quality of the audio
data is that something that's very
difficult to do
um yeah so I think they also depends on
um kind of the the perspective of the
the quality that we want to pursue I
mean
um also maybe even the audio quality I
mean like for the recording
Etc so
um for so our Focus was was on like the
quality of the speech um and on
transcript on pairs because we do the
alignment through the automatic data
Pipeline and also even like in the EU
website like foreign
like sometimes there's some missing um
sentences in in the transcription or
even say when um the speakers
um
present their speech they don't like
closely follow their their transcription
um so our filtering um processes
also is also like one to cover like um
these these um situations
cool thank you very much so uh I think
that's most of the questions then in the
uh in the comments so thank changing
again for for his time and for the
Fantastic presentation on the Vox
property data set uh so we hope that
you'll you'll use the data set as part
of the uh Define tuning event and it's
it's great that we've we've heard more
more about it uh so yeah thank you thank
you changing and uh yeah we've actually
released some uh code Snippets which
show you how you can um you can take the
common voice data set multilingual
Liberty speech box properly and uh
combine them all together so you can
really leverage uh the 15 languages with
label data in the in the Vox property
data set so we encourage you to go and
look at that and uh definitely check out
the box property data set
um so that's the the second of the
second and final of the two talks for
the uh whisper fine tuning uh speaker
events so thank you very much everyone
for joining and uh I'm sure you'll agree
that these are fantastic two set of
talks and um yeah we'll look forward to
seeing you in the in the Discord Channel
um so all the best way to find tuning
your whisper models
yeah thank you very much for your
attention
thanks Aaron